what we wanted to discuss today which is
something that we can all relate to
is
breakups
not mine
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters sophie and
sistine
you know the second we hit the record
button i don't know why my energy level
just went to a two i eat no but i came
in really pumped our energy level was a
two before this it's just been
consistently exhausted can i tell you
guys why we're exhausted yeah and y'all
are gonna make fun of us because you're
gonna say wow that's not exhausting you
are a bunch of pampered poodles true i
look like a pampered poodle right now
you really do mm-hmm it's giving it's
giving what
michelin yeah
rich mom ooh
i like that no you've got the pearl
earrings milf though
yes i know sophia your dream in life is
to be a milf she wants to be a milf so
bad is that why you want to have kids
sooner than later 100 you know it's the
earlier you get it the younger and
hotter you are so
honestly i love that for you
what do you want to be when you grow up
a milf yeah that's it what if you're a
one life goal not not to be a mother not
to be a wife not to be a ceo it's just
something
mom i love when people are like i want
to be a young mom so he's like no i want
to be a hot mom there's a difference
right i mean i'm going to be a good mom
but it would be great if i was hot along
with so let me this is a very
mind-bending
very intellectual conversation here
let me explain why we're a little tired
so
we had probably what a 14-hour
photo shoot day and you're like oh my
god
how does [ __ ] we're not models yeah no
we know actually we came into the shoe
with our looks our hair our makeup we're
like holy [ __ ] we look amazing right
killer like truly um like how i wish i
looked at pro honestly so good yeah we
see the photos and we're like
my eyes
my jowls what is it called is it all
yeah i don't know why
everything just got so much uglier and
pictures
can i say there's nothing more humbling
in life
when you're getting ready and you put on
a great outfit great hair you're looking
too america about six a.m so listen no
you there's nothing more humbling than
looking yourself in the mirror and you
go i look amazing
and then
you and your friends or they take a solo
photo of you and you look at the photo
and you just wanna
fall it was one of those moments where
like don't just delete it go into the
recently deleted you gotta
move it forever
you know when you double delete is when
you know okay i this is not a photo day
for me so we have to do this photo shoot
for something that you guys will see
very soon it's really exciting but it
was a promo shoot for something so we
did a bunch of individuals family shots
sister shots glam shots home shots
tequila shots we did all the shots it's
not just also being on it on camera we
like to also be on it off camera so it's
just well you're basically look we've
been in front of a camera for the last
like 14 hours that day
maybe a 30 minute break we did only have
30 minutes but here's the weird thing i
thought in my head you know
your girl when she was 15 she modeled
you know
i left montana over here cog here she's
that [ __ ] i thought um
it's gonna be like riding a bike like i
got this yeah i'm used to this anyone is
horrible at it
i don't know why no i think i looked the
worst no you did it sophia i looked the
worst we all collectively as a family
sat at lunch after that first look and
we were like we have never looked at
words
like not one person it's funny because
we're very obvious and very um we don't
have to hold back
no but like with each other's photos you
know i'm not going to say cestine looks
hot if she looks
horrible and that's a friend and that's
a friend and that's a sister so it was
so funny doing the group shots and the
individual shots and going back and
while we're doing the photos everyone's
going yeah work [ __ ] we've got the wind
blowing we're gonna do a leap
strut scarlet pose sophia please your
hands better no the more that they hyped
us the more i was feeling myself
therefore a worse picture came out of it
so we all run back to the monitor we
scurry over we're like ooh they're gonna
be amazing this is a good thing we use
forever and ever
and all of our faces dropped and we're
like
if this isn't pre-approved my ass
my face i don't know why i looked first
i looked like a melted candle
second of all
i honestly looked like someone had like
taxidermied my body stuffed it put on
like that funeral makeup and jess i
looked like a dead person at least he
just looked like a guy a 60 year old
mother from miami so she's trying to
still have it you looked like it wasn't
you were a bootleg version of the
beverly hills housewives intro
i like you know what i mean i literally
looked like i was a cast member and i
don't wanna be one i wanna be the one
yes yeah yeah like still trying to go
after my kids friends but like was
doesn't realize i'm old so bad and the
photographer even kept coming up to me
and goes think of a secret yeah you have
think things you guys think of a secret
so then you get that little glimpse in
your eye
and my secret was [ __ ] off it was dude
can you say it or you can't say it no i
can't say it oh i can't say it but i was
just thinking of like really gross weird
things i wasn't thinking of something
like oh i stole my mom's shirt you're
laughing my secret literally i don't
know why this came up it's so not even
hot at all
he said tell me like think of a secret
and i look at sistine and the first
thing that came out there was sistine
used to chew her lip behind her pillow
that's why the photos didn't come out
sexy because i'm thinking about
christine as an eight-year-old sitting
on her bottom lip sucking on her pillow
if that's your secret yeah i thought i
had multiple secrets one of mine was
i was like posing in the camera i'm like
you pissed the bed last year
accidentally
just like i thought i was trying to do
something hot but i really couldn't i
couldn't that's why the photos turned
out so bad what's wrong with us you know
i was trying to also think i was like oh
the trend sirenized i'm trying to give
sirens that everyone's like put your
head down yeah like make love to the
camera but i do have to give credit to
actual models because people always
think that it's not a real job it's not
that exhausting
i felt like i was hit by a bus by the
end of the day also it was so much work
you also
see the photos and you are you are hyper
aware and critical of what you look like
oh man i avoided mirrors the next day i
i couldn't i was just like i kept
brushing my hair every four seconds
before i shoot i was in the bathroom
every single second
up something i put on a hoodie that
covered my whole face when my boyfriend
came over after because i was like don't
even look at me he's like you look
beautiful i'm like i look like a troll
i'm like you did you see the melted
candle
he's like what are you talking about no
but i i you know i think we've come to
realize that once the scene hates
concerts and two we hate
photo shoots yeah but you know it's the
best thing when someone says you look
better in person
that's a compliment it's a compliment
i've heard that you look better in
person than on instagram i remember that
guy in florida said that i got hotter
throughout my photos he goes yeah you
weren't that pretty back then and
remember um he said like geezer said
that
you know your instagrams are getting
better yeah he's like you're you're
trying it's working that's great
whatever you're doing
thanks um to move topics cysteine uh
facetimed me the other day and was
peeing her pants laughing saying that
this was the most
hilarious situation ever happened to her
i was in absolute hysterics yeah because
i'm not one of those people that are
prone to accidents like you are tripping
or doing something in public that's
embarrassing it's always me witnessing
someone else doing that but this had to
be
top
number one this is number one the
funniest thing that is i've actually
never heard her do anything and the only
person that was there to witness it was
my aunt
and i was like oh my god i wish someone
had recorded this i wish you guys were
all there to see it i just couldn't i
like
i did pee a little because i was
laughing so hard it was hysterical so
oh i was editing the podcast yeah and
we're at my mom and dad's house
and i go you know what i want to be
healthy aesthetic i'm sitting outside by
the pool with my computer i'm like i'm
going to bring some water bring a little
snack like enjoy my time like try like i
never do that but i'm like we'll try you
know so
i've got a computer in one hand like
this
i've got a jug of water
nestled under my armpit like a gallon
jug yeah right just pulled it out of the
fridge like holding it like a football
against my body i've got another plate
in my other hand and i'm trying to open
a sliding door but i go uh oh i have no
hands now you're probably thinking why
wouldn't you just put one of the things
down open the door
go back in close the door right give me
like a challenge
i'm lazy as [ __ ] yeah we like to
challenge no it's called challenging
yourself i'm one of those people you
can't bring in just one grocery bag at a
time i'm having a nap like this
foot has the key
so i was like i've got great balance and
really wide feet my stability is good
yeah i put one door one foot up on the
sliding door to slide it out so i look
like a trapeze artist yeah juggling
plates on my nose and everything
i'm sliding open the door now buster our
dog
the door opens an inch and he [ __ ]
bolts for it he goes right for the door
and there's a coyote problem so we're
not trying to let them off outside off
leash so i was like no no no buster
it all happened so fast
i put my foot down trying to stop him he
goes in between my two legs i step on
his back
he gets nervous he goes behind my other
leg trips me like someone's doing one of
those bench
things to you know push someone over
trips me backwards the entire jug of
water
goes all over me like this like it was a
gallon and it was ice cold and not only
that you're probably thinking oh it got
a little on the floor the floor was dry
i was ringing water out of my underwear
i just washed my hair my hair was
sopping wet i mean it was like water
shot at my nose i stood up and it was
coming out of my nose i couldn't even
talk
and i could not stop laughing yeah and
i'm so upset that no one was there to
witness it because trying to explain it
right now you're like okay it's not that
funny it's no it's hilarious because we
all have those moments where
you look around you're like no one just
saw i was like is this
i just like fell over it was like a
cartoon it literally looked like
a sitcom like someone had scripted this
exact moment with the dog and the plate
in the foot and i'm balancing the
computer and i still held the computer
up as i'm landing i mean it was a
disaster it was a cartoon so make sure
you watch spencer's episode because
all of that for the sake of editing it
um please enjoy please enjoy her pain
speaking of embarrassing stuff
um since i've been kind of going through
it lately i've been going to meditation
classes and it's my safe place because i
feel
just so calm when i leave the class i
feel centered and it's just 50 minutes
of no distraction and breathing right so
i'm walking in so excited
i am feeling a little bit on edge i'm
like i need this so i wear these
sweatpants i got on revolve and this
crop tank that kind of matches it and
i'm grabbing some tea before class and i
see these two ladies sitting nearby and
they're probably in their 60s right and
they're just like skinny blonde chicks
just like staring at me right
and i don't really know why and i was
like
i kind of was looking at myself going is
there something on me that looks a
little weird and i kind of get near them
because i have to put my shoes in this
cuppy holder and all this stuff your
phone
and the lady was like we were just
staring at your sweatpants
and i go oh really like
they go yeah
we're just trying to read them because
they have a couple words on them all
over
and it goes
does that say dangerous attraction and i
go yeah yeah it does and at the top
there's a little
little cartoon figure it's an angel
holding like a little cartoon devil head
and it says come and get this head
right
right
okay
why is it i'm so far on the side of
these old ladies well oh yeah she said
she looks at my pants and she goes
that's pretty demonic of you to wear
well
demonic is a little extreme well first
of all she announced that in front of
the whole class and the teacher everyone
was staring at me and i don't actually
to be honest like i probably am saying
the phrase really wrong i don't know if
it was come and get this head it was
like something look it's a pokemon
fashion it's it's a popular brand also
when i bought it i didn't realize that
part of it okay what were they wearing
i'm like yoga pants from like lulu and
maybe something from like
outdoor voices because so why don't you
say isn't that a little basic well so i
it really honestly wasn't as bad as
they're making it i'm probably making it
sound a lot more dramatic the pants but
they made it so dramatic well what if
you just respond wait
and wait so i was just saying to them i
was like i got flustered i didn't even
know how to answer why do you let i
always make you feel though and i got
really flustered i go uh uh should i
leave the class and then they're like
well they're just pretty toxic and
things like that and i go holy [ __ ] so i
walk into the class kind of like heat it
a little bit that these women like i
need meditation yeah yeah and this
really sweet girl sexy music i think
she's like 19 years old and she's like i
just want to let you know i love your
pants
see she's like i don't think they're
demonic they're really cool so basically
she was the little angel and the devil
had all those ladies and i was like
who's ever called sweatpants demonic i
would have just demonic thrown it back
at them and just [ __ ] with their heads
a little bit more and been like yeah
cause i am the devil
something like that just to scare them i
know that time
it freaked me out i was i didn't know
how to respond kind of reminds me of
when we had that whole phase of haunted
clothing
yeah yeah but it's not but my pants
aren't haunted i just bought them
they're
well you should know you should test it
wear them out again i have one about
people have complimented me on my pants
like those pants actually i've had
babies you just spoke to the devil and
it was a test
i'd do okay we don't need to make this a
demonic discussion but yeah no it was it
was just kind of flustering i you know i
forget people can kind of be a little
bit more standoffish and cold in front
of an audience i don't know it just it
put me in my place a little bit not put
me in my place but definitely took me
back a little bit and i thought i was
more baller than that and i could stand
up for myself but obviously when pushing
you you got to work on that i'm like one
of those people in the shower i know
exactly what i want i love
hate when that happens when i'm like
having a fake argument with my shampoo
bottle and i'm like this is what i would
have said to this person 17 years ago
but i don't know why i kill those
arguments so well and then in person i'm
like
i should have said i should have said at
least like oh demonic's a bit aggressive
exactly like something it could have
been that it could have been like okay i
can send you the link later
it seems like you're interested in the
first place like something didn't say
i'll be sure to wear them again what a
conflict yeah exactly
anything i'm like i should be like oh my
god thank you i know just something
sarcastic sofia god damn it work on it
so i can't do it are you going to miss
me this weekend i know i am i am she's
going on vacation
i'm going to sun valley
idaho
home of the potato with her boyfriend's
family
i am and potatoes lots of potatoes do
you know how many different kinds of
variation of potato that i'm gonna eat
no mashed potato
sweet potato baked potato
crinkle cut potato air fried potatoes
potato chip of course potato chip waffle
fry
steak fry wow that's that's those are
just potato cuts those aren't those are
not just very smashed potatoes okay
smash potatoes
robert is that mashed potatoes mashed
potatoes
how do you feel about going um because
you've gone on trips with them but you
know we always say you know it's a
little bit you know what it was the
family i would say the first
the first time you do a trip with the
boyfriend's family it's nerve-wracking
yeah make a good impression but i think
i've already so comfortable with them
and they're comfortable with me so it's
not going to be like i have to
try to make them like me right we're
already there
at least you have to see this time
i know and i don't have to ski it's
going to be hot but here's the challenge
we're going golfing yeah but the last
time i went golfing was like the war of
1812. i am so rusty and that's what
makes me nervous because all we do is
talk about golf and we're going to be
golfing every day you're going to be
fine it's just nerve-racking well [ __ ]
no one's claiming that we're pga tour
girls like going off going we work every
weekend but also i look more like a cart
girl because my skirts are so short yeah
that i need to go buy some after i
bought her and i gave you mine you're
wearing it yeah and my boyfriend saw it
was like they won't let you on the
course at that point like seriously yeah
i wear that laptop
first of all it's a polo made of spandex
so not a polo crop top sleeves cut off
and a mini skirt
yeah i wore that
uh no one kicked me off
everyone kept me on
but uh i'm really excited
i think it's gonna be a lot of fun i'm
going fly fishing that's cool i'm gonna
put on overalls i'm gonna be like one of
those you're becoming more outdoor
tinder guys with like a fish picture i
want to post one of those you should for
sure get one of those
i know yeah and just like make it a
caption like this is how my tinder
profile would be caught dinner
for you and i
catching fish not feelings oh god it's
pretty good it's actually pretty good
there's many fish in the sea but you
have a photo of your boyfriend next to
you but this is the only two nights
that was pretty good you didn't even
live
many fish in the sea
um
we actually had a plan for this episode
yeah and
i know this intro is a little bit longer
than we probably anticipated but this is
the show it's our show it could be one
of them we have to give you updates
anyways but
what we wanted to discuss today which is
something that we can all relate to
is
breakups
not mine
like not
not leia's
not gabby because she's single
sophia
is officially
back on the market
yep so i don't know if you guys recalled
last week i was kind of in my feels and
i mentioned that and it was hard for me
to talk about it and i kind of started
crying but i feel like now i'm okay to
discuss and it won't be probably too
in-depth with what was going on just out
of respect for him but
yeah i'm single now which is kind of so
let's let's just go through all the
feelings the emotions i'm really proud
and happy that you do want to talk about
it because it's something that everyone
can relate to even if it doesn't have to
pertain to a
relationship breakup but a friendship
breakup a work breakup something leaving
something so i think someone can take
something away from this yeah and you
know so i
i really really really wanted to be in
love and i was without you know like
romantic uh yeah i'm a hopeless romantic
all i want in life regardless is i'm
very analytical about things i have my
checklist and all that stuff but at the
end of the day all i do is read romance
novels like all i want is to fall in
love and so it's it's been really sucky
and um this breakup hasn't been easy on
me i'll be honest like it hasn't no i
mean here to witness it's not been easy
and i feel like it's easy using social
media and your work and everything else
is a distraction but um i'm really glad
i've had you i've had my family i've had
my girlfriends like everyone has been
around me has been an incredible support
i think what's interesting is sometimes
the breakups that or the relationships
that only lasted four months are harder
to get over than the ones that lasted
two plus years because
when you've dated someone for four
months you're fantasizing and
visualizing what your life is going to
look like together how many kids you're
going to have how happy you could be
together before
you really see what it's like to be with
them long term and when you're with
someone for two years for example you
already know what your life would look
like with them yeah i don't think i
don't think it's necessarily for me the
length that makes it harder if it's
shorter or longer i actually think
sometimes the shorter the ones obviously
they think the easier it is
but i think with this scenario i mean i
put so much energy into it and i really
wanted this to work and i mean everyone
around me saw how much i wanted this to
work yeah
and it sucks at the end of the day when
you realize in your gut that
it's just not clicking as well as you
thought it was going to click and then
you have to be the one to make the
decision to end it sucks yeah and i feel
like i mean like i feel horrible i think
the hardest part about
when you're the one deciding to do it is
you're hurting someone that you really
really care about and you know at the
end of the day they're not going to be
happy with your decision and they're
going to be sad and you know you're
going to be sad but i always think about
how they're feeling more so of course
of course but it really takes i'm proud
of you for this because
it's obviously easier to stay with
someone
knowing that it's not i don't like being
lonely i feel lonely but it sucks
it's easier to just stick with it stay
with someone that you know isn't exactly
perfect for you or even close to perfect
because nothing's perfect it's really
easy to do that but it takes a very
mentally strong person
to pick themself over
someone else and you really loved him
and you put a lot into him and that's
why i know it's
people won't agree because we've all
broken up with and we've all been broken
up with
and everyone's always saying oh it's so
much harder to be the person that's
getting dumped
which in a lot of ways it is
but
you're
villainizing yourself automatically you
look like the bat even if you did
nothing wrong in the relationship and
you were a saint and you're choosing
what's better for you already the taste
is left in the mouth you're the villain
you're the bad guy for doing this i
think you're putting yourself over me
yeah i think breaking up with someone is
harder when there isn't a
really horrible reason to break up it
wasn't like there's
no
but there was reason there was reason
there was very but there wasn't just but
it wasn't like there was no cheating
there was no um there was no like name
calling there wasn't like that stuff
but
there were reasons but that's what makes
this whole thing harder is like
you don't have
something to hate the person for you
know like you're still so what about it
about it but so what about it
so what about what what made you
break up then
you know
i don't want to get into two specifics
no you don't have to get into the size
no but also
for this specifics no but this is what
i'll say because i feel like if anything
if you guys will gain any information or
like if you're
in this space of how i was like maybe
you'll learn something from it but
it's interesting when you're in a
relationship and you're in love and you
think before going into it that you have
all of this confidence and this
self-assurance that you are you know
what you deserve and maybe you found
someone that you're like oh they love me
i love them this works and it's going to
work and sort of like
the love you had in high school yeah and
you and you forget like
there are things that happen within that
time that aren't right but you let it go
because love is blind and you just want
it to happen because being alone is
scarier than being without someone
you know and everything especially you
and i we have an issue with
pacing ourselves when we start seeing
someone because we don't go out a lot we
don't get asked out a lot and then when
we do go out with someone we're like
okay well let's try to make this work
because the opportunity isn't there and
we want to be in love so you almost
expedite the process of getting to know
them before
you really know yeah and i think that
the love was still all there and maybe
you're with someone that you truly truly
love and you you feel it and you see it
but
there's something in your gut that and
this is the biggest advice i can go and
give anybody is
feel it in your gut and go with it if
you
are physically mentally
i mean if it outwardly is coming out of
your body that you feel that something
isn't right and maybe you f you mentally
don't think something's wrong but it's
coming out of you physically and there's
other ways where people are like are you
okay
then you need to start looking into that
and going why am i feeling this way
instead of kind of just going okay i'm
just it's a new relationship i'm anxious
it's this it's this is it so making
excuses but i feel like the biggest
blessing we have especially as women is
our gut instinct and we can feel it we
can sense it if something isn't working
don't ignore it don't ignore it your
body is telling you something's not
right right and it sucks because it
wasn't a bad at all relationship it was
a great relationship he was an amazing
guy i think you guys complimented each
other in a lot of ways
but
you're at the age and i could say
mentally i am as well where we're not
really looking to date anymore yeah
we're looking for a life partner we want
to be finding our husband
starting that exciting next chapter and
so
like when you started dating someone a
few years ago you weren't really there
yet so
probably you would have stayed with this
person if you'd met him a few years ago
because yeah the reasons why you broke
up with him
wouldn't work for you long term but
maybe back then you're like oh it
doesn't yeah exactly i could put up with
it
so what about this relationship do you
feel like
you've
gained and that you actually actually
really need for the next one well other
than the fact that
this time i actually will
trust my instincts
and not
waste my time and just keep saying i'll
be fine i'll be fine and ignoring what i
know and my god in my heart is the right
thing to do moving forward
but
it's also
to
not blur the line of
creating this
idealistic and like fantasy in my head
before knowing someone
you know i think it's really important
to take the steps and get to know
someone i think it's so beautiful if you
have love at first sight and you fall in
love so hard and fast and i know that
that was one of the most amazing
feelings i felt in this relationship but
i think it is really important to
remember who you are
and keep tabs on yourself going is this
the right one for me so for me moving
forward i need to do that i need to go
into a situation go
do i feel like truly that this guy could
work i mean like obviously give it
chances is obviously i think you need to
with your checklist that you have with
someone and everyone should have a
checklist of things that they absolutely
need in a relationship
more like the foundations the foundation
you should have at least an idea of what
you are and i think you could have
avoided a lot of
issue and heartbreak if you had stuck to
that checklist and we and we tried and
that's the thing is like it wasn't there
was energy put into it and so regardless
like i think it's important to try but
then also
there's a point of trying where it
depletes you and you don't want to
drain all your energy where you feel
like okay i can't fight anymore or like
i can't that's also been the hardest
part for you there's two things that
hurt me when you talk about your breakup
is one that you almost feel like
you
failed because you tried everything in
your willpower to make something work
yeah and it still didn't so it's almost
like you're mourning yourself right now
you're like i feel like
everything wasn't even enough yeah and
the second thing
is
you've
sort of lost this hope that you'll find
someone
so in a in a way sometimes like
non-stop you i won't find love it's not
going to happen i'm going to be so old
when it happens like you've lost all
hope and the interesting thing about it
when i talk to you
is that you're so big into manifestation
you manifest everything in your life
your business making money the podcast
your goals your dreams your ambitions
but the one thing you don't manifest is
your love life yeah i don't like you
really don't that's the one thing you
put on the back burner yet that's the
most important thing to you yeah that's
actually really funny i don't i like
don't put any thought into it and that's
why i was single these last three years
and then i met him
and then i was like this is just it i
felt it immediately and i go i i don't
even want to think about it because i
haven't thought about it i'm like oh it
just works it works you know because
i've worked on everything else in my
life so this has to just fit in that's
also another thing i think to point out
is that you
put an effort into all your areas in
life your work your friends yourself
whatever
and so someone comes along and you're
like oh they just fit well into it you
know like how could it not just click
but sometimes
it doesn't and i think that
don't
don't force them don't force something
you know and when it when you know
probably in the beginning it might be a
little bit harder and not work i mean
it's honestly so it's such a generalized
statement but it's basically saying
every single guy
in this planet
would fit into your life just because
he's a male you're a female
and that's who you're attracted to
do you know what i'm trying to say
no not really because we were just
talking about how
we assume that every guy that we go on a
date with it's gonna work it's gonna
click so we force it to work that's like
saying every single person that you're
gonna meet every girlfriend every friend
is gonna be a friend to you yeah it's
not everyone is compatible in the way
that we want them to be so that's why
it's really important to stick to your
checklist find things that
you actually need like for me i'm like i
prefer someone that lives alone very
family oriented has a nice job loves his
mom like that stuff's important to me
what what
you don't have to be in this
relationship but what are you absolutely
needing for the next one well this is
nothing this is not comparing
him
at all and this is just a general thing
that i care about um
obviously i love ambition i love someone
that's super family oriented but
you know i think regardless of all the
checklists and maybe whatever you have
i just missed the feeling of being in
love and i think that you guys if you
haven't been in a relationship for a
while and you're like i don't want to
look for someone i don't want to even
try and put an effort anymore honestly
try because like i forgot how that
feeling felt
and it seriously having someone that
loves you for you
and you love them for them and them
being your best friend is
i it's so indescribable from anything in
the entire world and like i want that
again and i think going into the next
one
i want to make sure that
my gut is telling me it's a it's the
right one and not to waste energy and
putting all this time and effort in
something that probably wasn't going to
work out in the first place but to also
feel those feelings again like i'm open
to it and i want it and i'm going to put
an effort to like find that person and
you know you will that's the thing like
you can't
go about saying it's not going to happen
for you i'm gonna be it's gonna be later
you gotta stop doing that because it's
you know that's not yeah you will find
your person you just gotta stop putting
a timeline yeah and this unnecessary
pressure on yourself well you know what
i it has been helping me a lot through
this breakup and i think that people and
this is like a side note because i just
remembered this that i wanted to bring
this up so if you're going through a
breakup and it has been really hard on
you like it was really hard on me for
the first i guess month of it like going
through it
the best thing that happened to me was
no communication and i have a really
hard time with that i'm one of those
people that even after i still like to
talk to that person and
at least
get to a middle ground or at least some
friendship i'll tell you god's gift to
us was the mute button on instagram it's
exactly like i'm telling you
seriously
cut them out of your lives as quick and
best as you can because you won't move
on
unless it's out of sight out of mind
truly like if you're looking at their
friends instagrams if you're looking for
their comments and their swipe ups and
they're this and their texts and their
calls like
it will
drain you and that's what i feel like i
was doing in the beginning but we also
didn't talk at all and that's helped
tremendously because i've been able to
focus on myself i've been focusing on
work and
some little distractions here and there
but i think it's really important
especially
when you're you're finally like single
again
is to focus on yourself all the energy
you put into the worry the fear the
the love the hate whatever put it back
into yourself so speaking of putting
back effort and energy into yourself
how are you now
going to use this breakup
to glow up
the post-breakup glow-up
don't do anything dramatic like get
bangs so that's the funny thing is the
first relationship breakup that i was in
um and that was a two-year relationship
and that was my like first love of my
life that was horrible like that i hated
that was such a bad breakup that i
actually physically went through changes
like i
was like i'm gonna get hot i'm gonna get
fit i'm gonna get blonde like i did
everything that i was polar opposite
front and i felt confident i felt good
but this time around i actually feel
like i am i feel like i'm physically
better like i do feel confident about
how i look but
i'm really putting all my energy into my
passions good and not and spending that
energy that i used to have going oh i
can't i can't i can't into going why not
you know i have all this time now i
can
put it into writing i can put it into
coding whatever i'm trying to do and put
into my career because the last couple
weeks all we've been doing is working
and so i've had nothing else to focus on
other than work and it's been really
cool to see
it actually getting better and seeing
things kind of come together
and so that's been my driving force and
that's what my mom did when my mom got
single after her and my dad split for a
second she started her own skincare line
and it's been running
since then to sell two billion dollars
in sales of her skincare products it's
definitely important and i think that's
really good energy and effort into
something different yeah it's so healthy
because staying in a dark hole
you're allowed to mourn and you're
allowed to be sad but you can't stay in
there too long because then it starts to
get a routine and then it's a habit and
then you'll never
be normal afterwards yeah you'll never
date normal after that you'll never
break up normal life i just think if
there's a lot of positive attraction in
your life if you're focusing on your
work and it's truly what you love like
that's the thing i also think i've been
focusing on things i don't
maybe i'm just doing to do not doing to
love
and i'm like okay if i focus on that and
like truly dedicate my time into that
and i also dedicate time it's like
growing my relationship with my friends
that i have with you
with experiencing life laughing then
that's when the person comes into my
life
and i feel like this time first time
around i was just
and he's an amazing person i have
absolutely nothing bad to say about him
and i'm being serious saying that um and
i fell in love and that was amazing and
i learned a lot from that relationship
but this time around you can't let them
flow no but you can't let the
relationship be your identity and but i
need it to
flow into my life seamlessly that's the
problem so rather than
you just shove like everywhere hold on
you stopped everything in your life to
focus on this relationship yeah whereas
that person didn't because that's normal
behavior he's like okay i still have my
work my friends my routine and i can add
my girlfriend and seamlessly and it all
fits still whereas you dropped
everything well that's my personality
i'm like one of those people if i don't
think i just dropped everything for that
person i'm gonna start to figure out how
to have a healthier balance but i'm
feeling better actually i feel like this
week has been the first week that i've
yay been feeling good which is nice um
and there's a lot of exciting things
coming up you're so blessed sophia you
have so many people that love and
support you in your life thanks
you'll be just a-okay look read the
shirt just keep on trucking you know
i will see you thank you for wearing
that shirt for me today obviously yeah
okay and to wrap up this relationship
talk show
we have an unsolicited advice
pertaining about relationships so if you
would like your question to be answered
make sure you go to our apple podcast
page leave your comments in the ratings
and reviews of course give us five stars
and that is the only way we are going to
answer it we're going to start doing it
every week so write in write in your
questions and we will answer them we do
we actually do we love you guys have
been lagging here so sophia take it away
it says help my best friends do not like
my boyfriend of seven months and they
finally told me what do i do
damn
that's
damn
rough you know what this is the thing i
can't blame the friends because
they probably you know when you don't
know someone in the beginning that
they're probably giving them their best
foot forward when you're meeting the
friends so he's probably getting along
with the girlfriend so they're fine but
then slowly as they start to hang out
with them how do you tell your friend
it's just i believe i have a lot of
questions how many times have they hung
out
when you're first meeting
your significant other's friends it
could be nerve-wracking maybe he like
dropped the ball on that one and got
nervous and quiet or was he
too extrovert and tried too hard like
there's a lot of ways it could go
and sometimes it could come off as fake
so i understand maybe the friends were
like what's this guy's deal unless he
hurt you
then i would understand well this is
what i would say is that
if your best friends are your best
friends and they know you better than
anybody else and they're questioning him
with you and they've never done that
before i
seriously would take that into
consideration and really take a step
back from the relationship stop thinking
about family stop thinking about
expectations stop thinking about
your fantasies all that stuff and
actually evaluate this person that
you're dating because
i mean i have never had anybody say
really to my face like they haven't
liked anybody it seems like a really
familiar situation to what you just went
through i think there were people in
your life telling you
there's a bit of red flags going on here
do you see them and ignoring them is the
worst thing to do i think it's really
important to confront it and nip it in
the butt and yeah i know and i get it
when you're in love with someone yeah it
is so yeah you're defensive it's so hard
to see past it but
i would try as best as you can to
actually sit down and go or ask them why
don't they like them and if it's a
stupid reason
then you go okay he was just nervous he
was just doing this and maybe you can
talk to him about that but i would not
confront the boyfriend first though no
you wouldn't i would not say
my friends don't like you
you're messing hell
you're messing up they're [ __ ] but
think about it if his friends went up to
him and said we don't like your
girlfriend
here's one thing that i did a big deal
when i was 19 i was dating this stupid
little boy
and um
one thing that i did was my girlfriend
told me
something's off with this guy i don't
like it i don't like the way he looks at
other girls i don't like what he says
about you
and i was so puppy love
blinded by everything he was doing
because i wanted it to work that i
basically shut her off
and chose him
which caused a huge conflict in our
friendship and then a month later she
was 100 right and trying to go back and
apologize and rebuild that friendship is
not only embarrassing that you would
choose someone so insignificant over
someone that is so yeah like close to
you yeah close to you and knows you
better than anyone so i would definitely
not ignore it but don't get defensive
address it in a sensitive way because
everyone's feelings like they're they're
looking out for you yeah obviously care
about like obviously don't shut your
boyfriend off in two seconds and like
completely dispel it but if these
reasons are he just has came and hung
out with us a lot and we just don't
think he's a nice person and we see
someone better like this isn't the one
for you yeah honestly
whatever it may be they're looking out
for you yeah they're looking out for you
i don't think people would just say it
to say it i think if because that's a
big deal i would never tell anybody i
didn't like their boyfriend even if i
was okay with them
never unless i truly thought that they
were
not right for them you know like
if they're your friends are doing that
with every guy then you just either have
bad taste in men or they're really
shitty friends
um but i think that if these are your
best friends and they don't usually say
that and they're saying it but this guy
uh
honey i agree hit the road jack never go
back so i think that just
wraps it up
perfect wow we're gonna have the hashtag
sofia single trending if everyone could
do that yeah my dms are open no they're
here so i don't read any of them
there's a crack in the dms in that door
slightly open with the blue check mark
for the right person
we're gonna get her back on that high
house oh god see i can't even picture
myself dating right now but you know
what hey
i want to wing woman you so hard oh god
sophia
i'm gonna be there at the bar sending
you drinks pretending i'm a dude i'm
gonna do all of it oh jesus all right
well we'll see how that goes because you
know i'm still
still awkward and bad at flirting so
submit
rex to um
yes
yes thank you for that suggestion if you
have any eligible men out there or
someone you know your brother your
brother's friend no your neighbor please
no
someone at your office
okay someone at the community pool we're
not we're not doing this i do not submit
your records
you don't have to look them i will suss
them out narrow them down we'll bring
them on the show live dating let's do it
if you're in the los angeles yeah we've
been trying to do this for years no now
we can finally do
sofia speed dating episode i know you
guys want it you gotta write in write in
today
do it okay we will see you next tuesday
i gotta get out of here bye
you